towards the end of last week I found
myself in the middle of a social media
Firestorm if you can believe it now I'm
not usually the sort of guy who makes
people on the internet mad in fact I
think this might be the first time in my
life that such a thing has ever happened
sometimes I don't know when you're
kidding I was trending on Twitter for a
few days because of some comments I made
about therapy mental health and
depression now to be clear therapy is
overrated overused and not nearly as
effective as people seem to assume
sounds good doesn't work I will just
mention this one response from a child
therapist on Tik tock
who was offended by my therapy
skepticism so let's just watch that I'm
Matt Walsh what's wrong with you uh yeah
I saw your Psychology today profile is
it true you can help me in only 5
minutes yes that's all the time I need
to fix you uh okay you take insurance
right of course but only if they're
owned by private Equity the government
can't take away my right to choose your
health care great is it okay if I let
you know what's going on
yeah I've already started the meter so
you better make it quick oh oh okay um
I'm lonely I don't know how to make
friends everyone keeps making fun of me
and I don't know how to talk to females
okay okay stop whining I know what you
need to do you're going to want to write
this down all right great what is it
stop it um I think it's a little bit
more complicated than that just stop it
stop looking like an idiot and make some
friends I mean I got to say the acting
and writing could have used a little bit
work but uh other than that pretty
spoton I mean that is unironically not
far from how my therapy practice would
work if I had one I don't know why he
had his eyes closed the whole time as
like as the idea that I was falling
asleep you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
make it through a day I would not make
it through a day as a therapist but if I
was a therapist it'd be pretty similar
to that although I'd probably model it
more after this scene from an obscure
HBO show nobody watched 10 years ago but
I like this one scene anyway cuz like
this is what therapy would be like if I
was doing it here it is so I'm not the
kind of therapist that foots
around I like to dig in Fast and I give
feedback stop fidgeting what are you
doing with your arm nothing I'm just
nervous put your hands in your lap Focus
sit up good posture sends positive
messages to the brain we're here to work
so what are your issues give them to me
well I am sad about this breakup I just
went through she left you yes and now
you feel rejected and unlovable and you
can't understand why she no longer loves
you yes you do know that she's not the
only source of love for you in the world
but I want her love we don't get
everything we want in life you don't get
to ever love that's it end of story next
issue again unironically that would be
good therapy what one of the big
problems with therapy is that in its
least effective forms it gives people a
forum to whine and talk about themselves
in a way that feeds the meter for the
therapist and gives the client an excuse
to be narcissistic and self-indulgent
but does not lead to action or change in
fact the therapist is incentivized to
not spark any lasting change because
that would interrupt the cash flow this
is a of a thing to say the fact is that
for most people in therapy the source of
their problems is not some complex
deeply hidden trauma they need to you
know have years of discussion to
identify and unpack but if therapists
give simple answers again they'd be out
of a job what a lot of people really
need is to be told exactly what you
heard In that clip which is this is the
way things are this is life You Can't
Always Get What You Want deal with it
stop complaining move on I mean that
that is the answer to like
99% of the emotional complaints that you
have lent the 40 days leading up to
Easter starts on Ash Wednesday February
14th this is a time of intense prayer
fasting and giving Hallow's annual pray
40 challeng is one of their most popular
last year over a million people joined
this year's pray 40 challenge focuses on
surrender and includes meditations on
the powerful book he leadth me this is a
story about a priest who became a
prisoner and slave in the Soviet Union
during the Cold War his story is one of
Ultimate Surrender and we are called to
offer up our own worries anxieties
problems and lives to God there will
also be lent music Lent specific Bible
stories and other Lenton prayers like
The Seven Last Words of Christ with Jim
czel you can download the app for free
at hall.com Walsh the app allows you to
set prayer reminders and track your
progress hallow is truly transformative
and will help you connect with your
faith on a deeper level download the
hall app today at hall.com Walsh that's
hall.com Walsh for an exclusive 3mon
free trial this led after a couple of
the steps into a discussion about
depression I'm just tired the days are
short I don't know maybe I'm depressed
there is is a difference between sadness
and depression but it is one of degree
not of kind depression is a deep
persistent sadness it's like the
difference between being hungry because
you skipped lunch and being hungry
because you haven't eaten in two days
they're they're both forms of hunger but
one is more severe and more debilitating
than the other so it's just a matter of
degree and the same is true of sadness
and depression depression is sadness to
a much greater degree I am dead inside
now it seems like there's no reason why
this point should make people so angry
that they call for me to be deplatformed
and fired for my job but that's what
happened the reason that it gets this
reaction is is is because most people
are programmed to lash out at anyone who
says anything that appears to fall
outside of the orthodoxies and teachings
of the psychiatric industry what don't
ask questions so for example one of the
one of the many clinical mental diseases
the psychiatrists have come up with is
something called Oppositional Defiant
Disorder which is a disorder
characterized by a child acting oppos
IAL and defined now it's definitely true
that some children many children even
all children to some extent do behave in
oppositional and defiant ways that is
very real but it's not a disease Kevin
you're such a disease sure but this is
what these people have done every
difficult human emotion or experience
has been arbitrarily and entirely
subjectively recategorized as a clinical
problem and if you think I'm making that
up you can go you can find the DSM you
can find it online you find you could go
through it and I guarantee you literally
every negative emotion has multiple
diseases for it and this is what has
happened with depression in my view
depression is real it is serious I do
not believe that it is a a disease
however depression is despair which
itself is again essentially a much more
persistent deeper more more encompassing
sadness I prefer the word despair so
despair I submit is not a disease
because it is a completely natural even
fundamental aspect of The Human
Experience it's called Being Human as we
diseas ify and medicalize all of these
difficult human emotions what we find is
that year over-ear the problems get
worse suicide becomes more common people
become less able to cope with the
challenges of life the strategy isn't
working and it isn't working because
it's based on a lie and it's a lie that
makes people feel powerless that it in
fact trains people to take comfort and
seek respit in their powerlessness so I
suggesting that it may be time to stop
and some of these basic presuppositions
realize that this is a field that has
been extremely disastrously wrong about
a lot of things that's all I'm trying to
say and I will keep saying it no matter
how angry people are about it and it's
why that industry is today once again
finally
canceled every Dr and we all remember
the proper ghost of the you feel better
cuz we study pharmacy at the best school
[Music]
ever